another way to talk about congruence and
remainder arithmetic is to work strictly
with remainders which makes things a
little simpler because you don't have to
worry about the fact that the product of
two remainders may for example be too
big to be remainder to knock it back in
range you have to take the remainder
again and that's what this abstract idea
of the ring of integers modulo and the
ring Z sub n captures in a quite elegant
way so it's going to allow us to talk
strictly about equality instead of
congruence and let's remind ourselves
that the the basic idea behind working
with a remainder arithmetic was that
every time we got a number that was too
big to be a remainder we just hit it
with the remainder operation again to
bring it back in range and so the
operations in Zn work exactly that way
the elements of CN are the remainders
that is the numbers from 0 with
including 0 up to end but not including
in so there are n of them from 0 1 up
through n minus 1 and the definitions of
the operations in Z and are given right
here addition is just means take this
sum but then take the remainder
immediately just in case it's too big
and likewise the product in Zn is simply
multiply them and take the remainder no
this isn't really a very dramatic idea
but it turns out to pay off in making
some things just a little bit easier to
say because we're talking about equality
instead of congruence so this package
together this mathematical structure
consisting of the integers in this
interval remember this notation square
bracket means inclusive and round
parentheses means exclusive so this
includes 0 and doesn't include n the
integers in that interval under the
operations of plus and times modulo Zn
as defined here is called the ring of
integers Zn so it's got two operations
and a bunch of things that are operated
on now I guess it's worth highlighting
that's what Zn is the ring of integers
mod N or modulo n now arithmetic in Zn
is really just arithmetic congruence
arithmetic except that
it's equality now instead of congruence
so we can say for example in c7 that 3
plus 6 is literally equal to 2 because
well 3 plus 6 is 9 the remainder on
division by 7 is 2 and we go directly to
the toe-in Zn suppressing the mention of
taking remainders and not even really
having to think about it which is what's
helpful about working with Zn likewise 9
times 8 is literally equal to 6 in Z 11
so what's the connection between the set
of all the integers and the integers mod
N and we can State this abstractly in
the following way let's just for
convenience abbreviate the remainder of
K on division by N is r of K so n is
fixed and what's the connection between
Z and Zn well it's fairly simple if you
take the remainder of I plus J that's
literally equal to taking the sum of the
remainders in Zn remember once you've
taken the remainders you're in the range
of numbers that Zn works with and this
Sun then keeps you in on the Zn side
likewise if you take the remainder of a
product of real integers that's
literally equal to the product of the
remainders in Zn this operation by the
way this connection between mathematical
structures the structure of the integers
under plus and times and Zn under plus
sometimes is called a homomorphism are
in this case is defining a homomorphism
from Z to Z and that's a basic concept
in algebra that you'll learn more about
if you take some courses in algebra but
I'm just mentioning it for cultural
reasons we're not gonna exploit it any
further or look further into this idea
ok
Oh what's the connection between
equivalence mod n or Congress mod N and
Zn well it's fairly simple
z in Zn we convert conferences into
equality's so I is congruent to J mod
and if and only if R of I is equal to R
of J in Zn and this is just a rephrasing
of the fact that two numbers are
congruent if and only if they have the
same remainder now once you've got this
self-contained system Zn
you can start talking about algebraic
rules that it satisfies and now they
hold with equality and they're pretty
familiar so let's look at some of the
rules for addition for example that hold
true in Zn first of all addition is
associative I plus J plus K is I plus J
plus K we have an identity element
literally zero zero plus any I is I we
have a minus operation an inverse
operation with respect to addition which
is that when I get back some slice gives
me okay let's keep going I have an
inverse operation which is that
therefore every I there's an element
called - I it's additive inverse such
that if you add I and minus i you get
zero and finally commutativity which is
that I plus J is the same as J plus I
you don't really need to memorize these
names but you will probably hear them a
lot in various other contexts especially
in algebra courses but even in terms of
arithmetic these are some of the basic
rules that addition satisfies and in
fact multiplication satisfies pretty
much the same rules multiplication is
likewise associative there's an identity
for multiplication called 1 1 times I is
I multiply so commutative the one
obvious omission here is inverses you
can't count on there being inverses in Z
N and finally there's an operation that
connects addition and multiplication
called distributivity namely I times J
plus K is IJ plus I K as you well know
from ordinary arithmetic and this rule
works fine for remainders and working in
ZN as i said the one thing we have to
watch out for it shouldn't be surprises
we know that you can't cancel with
respect to congruence mod n and that's
reflected in the fact that you can't
cancel in ZN namely in z12 for example 3
times 2 is equal to 2 times 8 again 3
times 2 is 6 2 times 8 is 16 you
immediately take the remainder to get
back to 6 in z12 these two things are
equal but if you try to cancel the two
you'd conclude that 3 was 8 and neither
3 3 & 8 are different numbers
in the range from zero to 12 and they're
different in z12 so you can't cancel two
okay now the rules that we already
figured out for when you can cancel in
congruence translate directly over to
when you can cancel in Zn and now
there's a standard abbreviation that's
useful to use here if I write Zn star
what I mean is the elements in Zn that
are relatively prime to n the elements
whose GCD with n is 1 so what we have is
the following equivalent formulations of
Zn star which correspond to the facts
we've already figured out about
congruence namely and ended your I in
the range from 0 to n is in Zn star if
and only if the GCD of I n n is 1 or I
is cancelable in Zn or I has an inverse
in Zn all of these three things are
equivalent they give you the sense that
Zn star is a kind of robust subset of Zn
that you want to be thinking about and
in fact it's very valuable to be paying
attention to what else do we know about
Zn star well the definition of fie of n
was the number of integers in the
interval from zero to n that are
relatively prime to n of course that's
exactly the size of Zn star so the event
is simply the size of that collection of
elements not surprising that we defined
that way so now we can restate euler's
theorem in a slightly convenient way
instead of mentioning congruence we can
just talk about equality euler's theorem
says that if you raise a number K to the
power fee of n it's literally equal to 1
in Zn at least for those k's that are
relatively prime to n that is those
cases that are in Zn star and it's gonna
turn out that the proof of what this
theorem is actually pretty easy just
follows in a couple of steps from a
couple of simple observations so let's
start on those so the first remark is
that if I have any subset s of elements
in Zn I don't care whether they're
relatively prime to n or not if I
multiply each of them by K this notation
for K times s means that I'm taking the
set of elements that are of the form
Kate
an element of s overall the elements of
s so K s which is this set of multiples
of multiples of elements of s by K has
exactly the same size as s now why is
that well this is course is only true
for K that our cancelable but the lemma
is no matter what subset you take of Zn
if you multiply every one of them by an
element that's cancelable in Zn star you
get a set of the same size and that's
clear because how could KS 1 and KS to
be equal well only if s1 and s2 are
equal or another way to say it is that
if you had different elements in s s1
not equal to s2 when you multiply them
by K you have to get different elements
of K s because K is cancelable okay so
that's an easy remark holds in general
multiplied by any subset by a cancelable
element and you get a new set that's the
same size the second remark is that if
you look at numbers I and J that are in
the interval from 0 to N in Zn then um
if you multiply the two of them um then
you're gonna get an element in Zn star
if and only if the original two elements
were in Zn star well let's just look at
it in the left-to-right direction which
is the only one we need if I and J are
relatively prime to Zn star then so is
their product because if neither I nor J
has a prime factor in common with n then
their product obviously doesn't have a
factor in common with N and then when
you take remainders it's still going to
be a number whose GCD is the same and so
we have this remark that if you multiply
2 cancelable elements you get a
cancelable element if you multiply two
elements relatively prime to Zn star you
get an element of Zn star there's about
every one of these formulations of Zn
star in terms of GCD SR cancelable or
inverse will and each of them gives a
separate and straightforward proof of
the fact that if I and J are in Zn star
then so is their product that's worth
mentioning by the way that in general
their sum is not if you add 2l
that are relatively prime to Zn star
even if their sum is nonzero you will
typically get an element that is is no
longer relatively prime and but for
multiplication that works great and
that's what matters to us okay so as a
corollary of this is that I can actually
conclude that if I choose an element
that's cancelable an element in Zn star
if I take the whole set Zn star all
those elements that are relatively prime
to n and I take multiples of K by each
of them then in fact I get the same set
Zn star and the proof of that is really
straightforward let's think about it for
a minute because what do I know is that
these two sets at the same size K Zn
star and Zn star the same size as long
as K is cancelable and even care that
this was Zn star yeah on the other hand
um if K is in Zn star K times the N star
it only gives you elements in Zn star so
kzn star is a subset of the left-hand
side and it's the same size by the lemma
that says that multiplying by K presumed
preserve sizes so they have to be equal
so basically what that means is that if
you take all the elements in Z star all
the elements relatively prime to n and
you take another one of them pick one
out of that set and multiply every
element in the set by that element K if
you had them lined up in one order
beforehand when you multiply by K you
get exactly the same elements but just
reordered that is multiplying by K has
the effect of permuting the elements of
Zn star let's look at an example so
let's look at Z 9 and we know that fee
of nine by the previous formula is three
squared minus three or six there going
to be six elements from zero to n that
are relatively prime to nine and that
are that comprised Zn star so let's look
at what they are so you can do check the
calculation but Zn star is exactly the
elements a 1 2 4 5 7 8 we know we got
them all cuz there's only supposed to be
six of them and we
can check that those are all relatively
prime to nine none of them has three as
a divisor now what happens for example
if I multiply them all by two twos
another good number it's right here
that's in Zn star and multiplying them
by two well let's check 2 times 1 is 2 2
times 2 is 4
2 times 4 is 8 2 times 5 is 1 because
it's 10 with a remainder of 1 2 times 7
is 14 translates into 5 2 times 8 is 16
mod 9 translates into 7 and as claimed
look at this
here's 2 4 8 1 5 7 it's the same numbers
as 1 2 4 5 7 8 just in a different order
let's do one more example well let's try
multiplying by 7 it's another
respectable element over here 7 times 1
is 7 7 times 2 is 14 which means it's 5
in Z 9 4 times 7 is 28 well 3 times 7 is
27 so that leaves a remainder of 1 and 4
times 7 is 1 in the Z 9 likewise 5 times
7 is 8 7 times 7 is 4 and 7 times 8 is
56 which translates to 2 and sure enough
as claimed I see the same numbers 7 5 1
8 4 2 just these numbers scrambled in
order they're per muted which is the
outcome of multiplying by 7 okay so
let's go back what we've just
Illustrated is this fact that we've
already concluded that if you take Zn
star and you multiply it by an element K
and Zn star you get the same set in a
different order so Zn star is equal to K
times en star and now we're on the brink
of proving euler's theorem because what
I want to do is say look these two sets
are the same let's multiply all the
elements on the Left together and
multiply all the elements on the right
together let's take the product of those
elements so let's take the product of Zn
star and compare it to the product of K
Zn star so big pie here is indicating
the product of all of the elements in
this set the product of all of the
elements in this set well um let's look
at the set on the right
this is the product of K times all the
elements in Z star well how many
elements are there fee of n elements in
Z star by definition and let's factor
out all the case so this expression here
the product of of K times each element
in Zn star is the same as the product of
the elements in Zn star times k2 as many
elements as there were namely k2 the fee
of n I'm just factoring k out of this
product and there's my k2 the fee of n
and now look what I got here that's PI
Zn star and that's PI ends Zn star what
do I know about multiplying elements in
Zn star there in Zn star this product
will be some other element in Zn star so
will this product but what do I know
about Zn star there cancelable so just
look at ignoring the middle term now
what I'm concluding is that the product
of Zn star is K to the fee of n times
the product of Zn star let's cancel
those cancelable terms and I'm done I've
just figured out that one which is the
result of cancelling the term on the
left is equal to K to the fee of N and
we have successfully proved euler's
theorem which is what we were aiming for
in this segment